welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and this is a breakdown of the book
of boba fett episode 1 which shows boba
fett's sticky escape from the sarlacc
making patton oswalt a freaking prophet
the gloved mandalorian armor gauntlet of
boba fett
grabs onto the sand outside the sarlacc
pit and the feared bounty hunter pulls
himself from the maw of the sand beast
this first episode was full of
interesting visual details subtle nods
of the broader star wars universe so i'm
gonna break down everything you might
have missed also you can make my back
dead dreams come true and support us by
checking out our exclusive merch with
our boba fett hunter and spider-man
strange entanglement shirts at
newrockstarsmerch.com
so we open on the twin sons of tatooine
rising over the palace of jabba the hutt
its interior halls and throne room all
looking as they did in return of the
jedi but now abandoned after boba fett
and benedict chan dethroned bib fortuna
in the mandalorian season 2 post-credits
scene meanwhile boba fett recovers in a
back to healing tank as we've seen
various star wars characters do
throughout the movies but inside boba's
eyes twitch as he flashes back to
memories seeing an attack of the clones
the stormy night at topoka city on
kamino where the ship of his clone
father jango fett waited to depart
before they fought obi-wan kenobi
actually i think you can see young boba
in the ship's cockpit there but we never
actually saw this particular angle of
the city in attack of the clones meaning
this is an archive shot that they
recompose for the series spoiler warning
for the animated bad batch series after
order 66 this depoka city and its
cloning facility fell under imperial
control and then was decommissioned and
then they bombed this city under the
orders of tarkin all witnessed by the
bad batch and omega who is revealed in
that series to be another clone from the
django strain and therefore a sort of
cloned sister to boba fett whom who
knows we may see a live action on this
series then boba flashes back to that
moment in the geonosis arena an attack
of the clones when he held the helmet of
his father after django was beheaded by
mace windu during that battle and before
you freak out that jango said could
still be in that helmet no no the vfx
team in that movie included the shadow
of his head falling out of that helmet
but the shot here has also been altered
from the original release because we now
see bobo running up to the helmet and
then a new close-up that frames his face
in the t-shaped visor for telling his
future under this armor and then a wider
crane shot that makes boba look even
more isolated they also removed the
corpse of the reek that jango had just
slayed moments before his death so being
submerged in this fluid then triggers
boba back to the belly of the sarlacc in
return of the jedi after a blind han
solo knocked into his jet pack and sent
him bouncing off the yacht into the
sarlacc's mouth now faces the fate
described by c-3po in his belly you will
find a new definition of pain and
suffering as you are slowly digested
over a thousand years and now we get to
see and smell and hear and feel that new
definition of pain and suffering all
from boba's perspective down to the
beating of the sarlacc's heart if you
listen
closely and you can also hear the
sarlacc squeal way up above
which is the same sound effect from
return of the jedi
since he is now on his dying breaths
boba to survive has to take oxygen from
a stormtrooper's helmet since the air
down here would not be breathable that
stormtrooper is being absorbed into the
tissue wall as fluids corrode his armor
now if you remember there were not any
stormtroopers in that scene in return of
the jedi so this guy must have been
slowly digested for several years at
this point maybe this guy was part of
the same search crew who was looking for
3po and r2 in the 1977 film hopefully
that a-hole who torched owen and beru so
boba activates his flamethrower to burn
and claw his way out of the belly and
then like a zombie crawling back from
the dead he bursts his hand out of the
sand behind him you can see the wreckage
of jabba's yacht and a sandy sarlacc
tendril limp on the dune maybe this is
the one that han shot in order to free
lando at no point do we see the sarlacc
speak so if you were one of the purists
who were less enthused with the 1997
redesign there's no sign of it here
director robert rodriguez includes a pov
shot from within the helmet as the t
visor crosses the glare of the first sun
and then the second sun later on jawas
roll up and pry boba's armor off this is
the same group that cop van later came
across in the mandalorian chapter 9 in
order to obtain that armor then he's
approached by some tuscans now yes they
do not travel in a straight line here as
obi-wan said they always do to hide
their numbers but this is also in a
sandstorm which hides their numbers just
fine and they do later ride their
banthas in a straight line so shut it
one of these tuscan squirts worm fluid
into boba's mouth and then he's like ew
yuck this could actually be the smelly
dung worms of mazespa mentioned in the
phantom menace game
so they ride the banthas and they tow
boba behind them as a prisoner and then
he just gets dragged on his back the
overhead visual evoking the way maximus
was enslaved in gladiator also a
character who rose high in the world
composer ludwig joranson returns to the
mandalorian to score all of this in this
case with some men's choir vocals
it's not that common to hear vocals in
star wars music aside from the duel of
the fates and the emperor's theme both
of those songs best identified with
characters who had unlikely
resurrections like boba fett does here
the tuscans have with them a massive
these are the doglight creatures that
often accompany tuscans we saw them in
attacking the clones and in mandalorian
chapter 9 when denjarin knew how to tame
them this episode's title is stranger in
a strange land which is the title of a
1961 sci-fi novel by robert heinlein but
way before that it's from the book of
exodus referring to the second son of
moses who is historically overshadowed
by his father and then this son or
really son figure clone of jango fett
has until now really remained in the
shadows a stranger overshadowed by his
father's legacy as the man from whom all
clone troopers were cloned from but now
the sun forges a dynasty of his own his
reputation was that of a stranger but
soon he will prove that he is far more
familiar with this strange terrain of
tatooine than the crime lords that he
seeks to rule even boba just cooks in
the twin suns i love all the prosthetics
they put on his face to make his skin
peeling this episode and in this tuscan
camp he gets poked by this kid this is
actually played by wesley kimmel nephew
of jimmy kimmel who also played the
commercial kid in one division meanwhile
the tuscan chief is played by xavier
jimenez who played a tuscan raider in
mandalorian chapter 9 and that female
warrior is played by joanna bennett a
stunt performer in several mcu films was
a stunt double to emily van camp and
bree larson boba fusses with his ropes
in plain view of the awakening massive
who just stares him down and gradually
approaches him but really boba just did
this in order to lure in the massive
close enough to chokehold him and then
pat him to sleep and then use the
animal's razor-sharp teeth to cut his
ropes and you'll notice throughout all
this other than his lined the rodian in
the language of the jawas and the
tuscans these opening 12 minutes are
fully without dialogue making it some
pretty great visual storytelling and by
the way this rhodian prisoner was
actually secretly voiced by sam witwer
the amazing darth maul voice actor
then this nighttime gloom suddenly
solarizes into high contrast as bobo
wakes up to fenix shand his mercenary
companion whom he saved on tatooine
after she was left for dead in chapter 5
of the mandalorian they both suit up in
their armor bobas includes his signet
that we've always seen if you look
closely it shows a wheat sheath a drop
of blood and what looks like an arabesh
d now that we know that this armor
includes his father's chain code that
explains his whole mandalorian lineage
i'm wondering if this signet could be
connected to his father's history with
jasper muriel and their experience on
the mandalorian planet of concord dawn
and then of course he's got the
signature dent in his helmet which was
going to be shown in an unfinished clone
wars arc in which boba fett dueled with
cad bane hopefully this backstory will
come up in another flashback duh yes yes
i know sifting through all these details
can make things very complicated when
you're trying to understand these things
sometimes it feels like trying to
understand how cryptocurrency works
right but here's the thing you don't
have to be a galaxy brain playing 4d
chess with elon musk to invest in
cryptocurrency public.com is here to
help even if you're still struggling
with duty jess public.com is an
investing platform that helps people
become better investors members can
build a diverse portfolio of stocks etfs
and crypto within a single platform what
makes public so special is public
combines the ease of fractional
investing with an educational community
that makes it possible to learn and
build your confidence public now offers
20 different cryptos for you to trade
including bitcoin ether dogecoin and
even shiba inu they also have
educational resources and volatility
reminders to keep you informed there are
zero commission fees on standard trades
and no account minimums to get started
it's also backed by big names like tony
hawk will smith and some of the original
investors in venmo new rockstars join
public and you can see what trends we
are following if you search for at new
rockstars in the app so go to public.com
new rockstars and receive a free stock
between three dollars to three hundred
dollars when you open an account with
public and deposit the aqualish leader
is named garfolkwax and he's played by
barry lowen who's played a stormtrooper
throughout mandalorian season two he
offers a bunch of credits that are
marked with the insignia of the new
republic considering they have now
replaced the empire and their imperial
credits at this point in history you can
see the silver ones are stamped with the
arbesh symbol for currency and none of
this is subtitled because they don't
have a protocol droid to translate we
really need a protocol droid now
technically c3po is still around at this
point in history but he's probably
serving leia organa in her leadership
role with the new republic on chandrila
or wherever leia is at this point now if
you look closely among that awesome
concept art during the closing credits
there is an illustration of boba on the
throne with some protocol droid head on
a platter at his feet instead they use
ad8 that's jabba's torture droid
returning from return of the jedi but
now he's voiced by toast of london and
what we do in the shadows actor matt
barry presenting doc's drasti leader of
the trandoshan family protectors of the
city center and its business territories
meanwhile dr strassie is played by
robert rodriguez himself it looks like
he's carrying a wookie belt you remember
in empire boba fett wore a braided
wookie belt on his armor rodriguez will
also voice the mayor of mos eisba
makshays who here snubs boba fett and
sends his major domo a twilik played by
dave pasquezi character actor from beep
a whole bunch of other stuff first and
foremost to me a legend of improv comedy
with his partner tj jacobski two guys
whom in 2009 i forced my college improv
team to drive four hours to go see why
was i bending over in this photo why
didn't philip take advantage of that
pose oh wait he did but swayze brings no
tribute and even after getting
threatened this guy's got the balls to
demand tribute from them the mayor may
take it differently but i shall indeed
convey your sentiment but notice how he
waits until he clears the rancor pit
trap door before turning back insane i
would not be surprised if you receive
another delegation in the near future
remember luke killed a rancor but only
one of them and in bad batch we learned
of another young rancor named moochie
young at that point in history probably
fully grown now and at the end of that
episode bib fortuna did pick up that
rancor we may see him on this show but
boba fett decides to pardon two
gamoreans who were loyal to the past
masters which is a crucial step by boba
improving his different leadership
philosophy i intend to rule with respect
and then on to the city of moscespa we
visited this city in phantom menace as
well as attack of the clones and the
various things we saw in those movies
like watto sabolba the other pod racers
maybe anakin's old friends like kinster
banai could all still be around this
town here they stroll past a few droids
that look like customized versions of
the real-life boston dynamics robots and
then into the sanctuary cantina where
max rebo and perhaps figure and don
return max was on jabba's yacht and
return of the jedi somehow survived if
you listen closely the music they are
playing is actually a modified version
of the classic cantina theme
[Music]
the background at the bar is an ra7
protocol droid the bartender looks like
a hask and then there's a gambling table
run by a droid wearing a green visor
this is the same kind of droid as r3x or
rex who djs and ogus cantina and
disney's galaxy's edge which i've spent
quite a bit of time at in recent months
don't get the fizzy drink it hurts some
sexy twilics fill their helmets with
tribute credits as cantina owner gossip
whip jennifer beals greets them and you
are always welcome
as it is yours now yeah she plays the
act well but it seems like garcia
doesn't yet respect boba's rule and
might have had a role in the ambush
outside which is probably that second
delegation from the mayor that the major
domo referred to the assassins use
electro staffs like the one used by
general grievous and revenge of the sith
also red tinted shields likely the same
tech as the shielding on that boo that
darth maul qui-gon and obi-wan dueled
through at one point boba lends his knee
to boost fennec but really their opening
is thanks to the gamoreans who show how
boba's choice to rule with respect pays
off more than ruling with fear this
whole debate over how best to rule
really goes back to political theorist
machiavelli who pondered whether it's
better for a ruler to be feared or to be
loved machiavelli's conclusion is that
the most virtuous ruler is governed by
no single dogma but really applies
whatever response is necessary according
to each situation the ends justifying
the means so applied here boba fett's
desire to be respected really must be
balanced by finnex shan's desire to be
feared and only together does this good
cop bad cop routine function according
to the true machiavellian philosophy
they're able to overwhelm the assassins
who try to escape but boba pulls off
favro and straight up iron man's one of
them
meanwhile finnick parkours after two
others and needing only one to
interrogate for information kicks the
other off the ledge but then another
flash backed up to boba's time with the
tuscans where the child leads him and
the roadie into a moisture farm that's
been robbed by nekto raiders who leave
this interesting symbol now these guys
helmets don't really look like the blue
mining collective helmets that were worn
by that gang that took over moscow go in
mandalorian chapter 9 they could be the
red key raiders which is the version of
the gang that vance defeats in chuck
wendig's aftermath books but i think
those guys have a different symbol i
think we're probably looking at a new
crew the symbol does look kind of like
an orbesh tea and they are nikto's the
same race who held grogu in the
mandalorian pilot episode we go into
some theories on who these guys could be
in our wikileaks after show and another
reminder that maul's crimson dawn
organization could still be active even
if maul himself met his end with obi-wan
during rebels shortly before the events
of a new hope i assume we'll learn more
about these guys in coming episodes but
yes this moisture farm does look a lot
like the lars homestead where luke
skywalker grew up but that farm was
closer to moss eisley and according to
the star wars complete locations book
the lars homestead is about 168
kilometers from mos espa which is pretty
far from the dune sea where the tuscans
had boba so i'm guessing this is just
one of the other countless moisture
farms on this planet as they dig for
water the roadian snaps at boba
[ __ ]
is a slur translating to slime ball
which we heard anakin say to sabolba and
phantom menace just granny doe pot slamo
then boba fett mentions heading to
anchor head to get off world anchor head
is an old settlement first mentioned in
the 1977 film look i can take you as far
as anchor head
you can get a transport there to mos
eisley or wherever you're going but
rhodian accidentally uncovers a
six-armed beast who attacks now i don't
think this creature is known in any star
wars canon but its design does evoke the
stop-motiony aesthetic and designs of
ray harryhausen i actually love how it
can grizzly bear up on its hind legs and
use its four top limbs like goro and
mortal kombat but then can also shift
its middle legs down to the ground so
then it can run faster kind of like a
centaur and oh this is so sad as it
presses down on the rodian the rodian's
hands just go limp but boba manages to
slay this beast by using his own slave
chains to strangle it just like how leia
used her slave chains to strangle jabba
the hutt the crime lord that boba fett
is now supplanting back at the camp the
child returns with the beast's severed
head suggesting this monster might have
plagued the tuscans as a kind of
boogeyman it's looking like this kid is
taking credit but boba allows it because
the chief knows better sharing with boba
a drink of water a crucial token of life
here in the arid desert the most
important detail of this moment boba is
carrying this kid's simple wooden stick
that he grappled over this whole episode
it looks like it's a low-level training
stick as this young lane works his way
up the tribal hierarchy to the fully
formed curved gaffy stick carried by
tuscan raiders as you see the chief
wielding and when we saw boba first show
up on the mandalorian he carries one of
those fully formed ornate gaffy sticks
showing that this guy will one day rise
to the higher ranks of this tribe and
right here he is taking the first step
of that journey from the lone wolf
bounty hunter to a trusting member of a
collective a lesson that as ruler of
jabba's cartel he will try to pass on to
the people who are least receptive to
that critical message and i can't wait
to see him try a reminder that our
strange entanglement shirts one of my
favorite all-time shirts from new
rockstars is available at
newrockstarsmerch.com along with our
boba fett inspired hunter design both of
them are limited edition both are going
to sell out quickly so get your hands on
those and follow me at eavos follow new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more analysis of everything you love
thanks for watching boba
[Music]
you